Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard schönen
guten Morgen Markus
deine Stimme klingt ja noch was tiefer
als meine möchte ich sagen ich bin so
ein ganz klein wenig erkältet ja ich bin
ein kleines Licht
bist du wirklich so wenig ja toi toi
meine Güte eine stabile Gesundheit der
Richard ich ich bin ja ich bin ja
ständig wirklich mich erwischt ständig
ich muss muss ab richtig Schiss weil ich
hatte jetzt diese Woche habe ich jetzt
irgendwie hingekriegt und auch eine
spannende Woche sehr interessant auch
die Corona nach Betrachtung mit Karl
Lauterbach es war wirklich spannend ähm
eine der interessantesten Sendungen die
ich glaube ich jeder hier bei wohnen
durfte und ähm am Sonntag aber wenn wir
in Lübeck unseren großen Grönland
Vortrag zeigen ja und da rede ich dann
sehr sehr lange auf der Bühne und ich
weiß nicht wie das gehen soll ich habe
sehr sehr schön ja
solange noch was rauskommt ist alles ich
finde wenn man also sozusagen nur leicht
er Ergebnis oder der kehlkopfen also so
leicht tangiert ist wird die Stimme
eigentlich erstmal interessanter ja es
geht in Richtung very white aber dann
halt jetzt irgendwann wird irgendwann
wird es schwierig ne nach du weißt ja
nach fest kommt ab ja was bei Handwerk
angeht gilt auch in der Stimme wenn es
irgendwann so richtig und je mehr Barry
White desto gefährlicher wird man es ist
weg egal Richard ich freue mich total
auf die heutige Folge ja weil ich weiß
dass du dich mit dem Thema schon länger
beschäftigt hast künstliche Intelligenz
ist das Stichwort alles redet über Chat
und wir haben uns das mal angesehen
weißt du was also als kleine Einleitung
nur als kleinen Gedanken ne 1879 hat er
diesen die Glühbirne erfunden ja und ähm
das war sozusagen eigentlich der
Startschuss zur
Elektrifizierung der Welt genau
Revolution so aber
erstmals gar nichts passiert
genau wie immer und es hat dann 40 Jahre
gedauert bis das Ding aber dann mit
Karacho zurückkam und mich erinnert das
wir sind ja so mittel alte Menschen
Silver Surfer wie wir ja sagen
an den neuen Markt erinnerst du dich als
plötzlich alles am Neuen Markt
investiert war und ich weiß.com ja aber
auf dem Flughafen sich erinnern
auf dem Bio data ja und ähm an ja genau
also wunderbare Rechte Händler der Name
jetzt nicht nennen wollen die dann mit
Yachten von Monaco kreuzen ja em-tv und
jetzt mal deutlich zu sagen ja die
Rechte haben Biene Maja plötzlich
erworben hatten und alle dachten es
werden alle Milliardäre und ich weiß
noch genau auf den Fluren von RTL Leben
mobile Kapitalismus war geboren ja gar
nicht gibt genau werden richtig und die
haferbrüder damals und ich weiß noch auf
den Fluren von RTL
liefen jeden Tag Leute herum wirklich
vom Cutter zum Kameramann zum Redakteur
ja wie alle da mittendrin und alle
raunten sich irgendwelche Sender zu
nennen neuen Börsenwerte zu und keiner
fragt der Sommer haben die eigentlich
überhaupt ein Zuhause wo wohnen die
eigentlich und ich glaube meistens
hatten sie noch nicht mal eine Garage
sondern bestanden als aus zwei
Schuhkartons und dann brach das ja alles
zusammen und ich weiß noch wie viele
Leute damals den abgesangen aufs
Internet angestimmt haben und dann kam
es mit gigantischer Macht zurück es war
nicht aufzuhalten plötzlich war dann
google da und dann war plötzlich
Facebook da also Meta heute und so
weiter die ganzen großen Konzerne Amazon
fing an als kleiner Buchhändler Jeff
Bezos kam die Geschichte finde ich bis
heute so ihre kennst du die Thomas
Micheldorf ist Vorstandsvorsitzender bei
Bertelsmann
der Thomas mittelhofft der dann später
im Gefängnis gelandet ist und ein sehr
beeindruckendes Buch darüber gemacht hat
den habe ich mal persönlich ausführlich
kennengelernt ja
okay okay so und der erzählt diese
großartige Geschichte wie ein junger
Mann ein nerdiger junger Typ mit einer
schlecht sitzenden Karotten Jeans und
einem Rucksack an einem schwarzen
Rucksack auf dem Rücken in diese
gigantische Firmenzentrale in Gütersloh
und Bertelsmann reinmarschiert und sagt
was auf wie hat doch da diesen Buchclub
und vielleicht wäre es eine Idee wenn
wir uns irgendwie ein bisschen zusammen
tun würden und so weiter weil ich habe
auch vor Bücher zu verkaufen ja ich
mache das aber übers Internet und so
weiter und vielleicht ist das ja eine
Sache und er präsentiert da vor diesem
Vorstand die lassen den kalt abtropfen
und es war halt jetzt leider Jeff Bezos
ja das weiß
ein paar wenige million einen
Großaktionär bei Amazon zu werden
Wahnsinn und ich denke heute manchmal
wenn das damals funktioniert hätte wird
es Gruner und Jahr heute vielleicht
besser gehen so schließt sich der Kreis
jetzt auch traurige Geschichte quasi
wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe
aus zwei Perspektiven also einmal
sprichst du von dem spekulativen
maßlosen Überschätzung bestimmter
Entwicklung und zum anderen
unterschätzen genau
ja richtig dass der Punkt und die Frage
ist was ist jetzt Chat GPT ja genau so
ein Ding ist das also
oder ist es eher Amazon möchte ja genau
es ist em-tv oder ist es so und mein
Gefühl ist äh es ist sowas von Amazon es
ist die Möglichkeit
gigantische unvorstellbare Datenmengen
zu verarbeiten und die die die
Technologie dahinter ist aber eine die
auch beide Seiten glaube ich hatte die
unglaublich viel bewirken kann im
Positiven
lebe auch echte dunkle Seite hat und
darüber würde ich gerne heute mal mit
dir reden Richard du hast dich ja mit
künstlicher Intelligenz wobei mein Sohn
sagt KI künstlich ist eigentlich der
völlig falsche Begriff derzeit alle
deutschen Informatiker die meisten
Deutschen Informatiker mögen in
Begriffen aber weißt du warum die
Begründung ist richtig er sagt lasst uns
von Maschinen learning sprechen ja
Maschinen lernen und jetzt in der
allgemeinen Bevölkerung nicht so an also
musste seine Produkte aufwerfen können
ja und das Wort Intelligenz na das
leuchtet jedem ein lieber künstliche
Intelligenz als natürliche Dummheit ja
das ist natürlich nicht schlecht wenn
die Maschine das können so das ist und
deswegen ist es also erstmals
ich habe gedacht ne ich mach bei dir
heute den Big Point ja wenn ich mit wenn
ich sage weißt du das ist gar keine
Intelligenz und dann hörte ich Richard
schon sagt Markus du hast total recht
weißt du Intelligenz ist etwas völlig
anderes Intelligenz ist wenn man etwas
begreift das ist die diese Dimension
menschlichen Seins Markus und damit hat
künstliche Intelligenz nicht das
Geringste zu tun stattdessen fällst du
mir in den Rücken okay egal naja so
richtig in den Rücken Fall ich nicht
also ich versuche mal zu erklären warum
der Begriff nützlich ist und als zweites
würde ich sagen ja ich habe was
philosophischer Perspektive natürlich
auch ein bisschen Probleme damit es gibt
ja keine zuverlässige gute Definition
dessen was Intelligenz ist gibt es
tatsächlich nicht also es gibt Unmengen
von Definitionen sie sich teilweise
überlappen teilweise ausschließen manche
sind einseitig andere sind schwammig
meine lieblingsdefinition stammt von
Jean piaggi also dem Schweizer
Entwicklungspsychologen der gesagt hat
Intelligenz ist das was man einsetzt
wenn man nicht weiß was man tun soll es
wird Abstand für mich elegantes die
Definition von Intelligenz und wenn das
so Grundlage gemacht ist dann kann man
sagen gibt es keine künstliche
Intelligenz weil die Maschinen ja jetzt
genau darauf ausgerichtet sind dass Sie
immer wissen was sie kommen sollen also
der Zustand dass die Maschine nicht weiß
was sie tun soll der ist eigentlich ein
Unfall im System das ist nicht etwas was
als Ausgangssituation dargestellt wird
genau so im Gegenteil die Maschine wird
so programmiert dass sie eben für alles
irgendeine Antwort hat
und dass sie nicht in einer
unsicherheitsphase ist sondern immer in
sicheren Gewässern ja in festen
regelbasierten Umgebungen indem sie weiß
was sie tut genau und das wäre
strukturell etwas anderes als
menschliche Intelligenz und nun kann man
ja künstliche Intelligenz anders
definieren als menschliche Intelligenz
und sagen die Piaget Definition gilt
halt nur für menschliche okay aber lass
uns jetzt mal ganz konkret rein in die
Anwendung Richard das ist ja so spannend
ne es gab jüngst eine Meldung aus den
USA aus Amerika zwei US-Wissenschaftler
am
in Eli neu glaube ich die wissen wollten
wie gut Chat GPT juristische Probleme
löst ja und und dieser Chatbot
sollte nichts weniger als ein
us-juraexamen ablegen und das Ergebnis
war hat es geschafft in manchen
Rechtsgebieten scheiterte Computer in
anderen besteht der und teilweise sogar
mit überdurchschnittlich guten
Ergebnissen
sehr einfach machen und sagen also ich
bin ein guter Bekannter von mir ist ein
absoluter Top Jurist und da mein Sohn
sich mit dem Gedanken trägt Jura zu
studieren und wir ein bisschen über die
Voraussetzungen die man haben muss um
Jura zu studieren sparen und hat er den
interessanten Satz gesagt Jura hat
nichts mit Intelligenz zu tun
also insofern wäre das jetzt kein Beweis
für künstliche Intelligenz sondern der
sagt Jura besteht erstmal darin dass man
mit einem unglaublichen Fleiß sich
wahnsinnig komplizierte Strukturen drauf
schafft wenn man die sich aber einmal
drauf geschafft hat dann geht es einem
eigentlich ähnlich wieder über
künstliche Intelligenz dann weiß man
eigentlich immer was man tun soll also
auch der Jurist versucht ja genauso wie
die Maschine in eine Situation zu kommen
in dem keine Unsicherheit besteht
[Musik]
und man könnte ja zu andere
Anwendungsbereiche von Intelligenz
machen wo es einfach in der Natur der
Sache liegt dass man nie so richtig
festen Boden unter den Füßen hat und der
gehört Jura nicht zu und deswegen ist es
nicht ganz so überraschend dass gerade
auf diesem Gebiet ja Chat zu Hochform
aufläuft
aber Jura zum Beispiel wenn wir jetzt
über die Frage reden werden Juristen in
Zukunft von von einem Bot von einer
Maschine ersetzt also fällt dieser Beruf
beispielsweise Weg
ja das sage ich auch so also die gleiche
die gleiche Diskussion als ich das Buch
über künstliche Intelligenz geschlagen
habe also vor 30 Jahren
das Buch schrieb künstliche Intelligenz
und der Sinn des Lebens da gab es Chat
GPT in dieser Form noch nicht aber
what's Watson diese berühmte semantische
Suchmaschine und damals war die große
Diskussion wird Watson Juristen ersetzen
und da gab es also spektakuläre
Hochrechnung die gehen in den nächsten
zehn Jahren werden 60% aller Juristen in
den Vereinigten Staaten und so weiter
ihre Arbeit verlieren
und das ist alles ja bislang nicht
passiert wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht
so passieren weil dann kann die
Glühbirne nein nein nein weil man
verschiedene Dinge unterscheiden muss ja
du glaubst doch nicht im Ernst dass du
wenn du jetzt eine Ehe
Auseinandersetzung hast und du stehst
vor dem Scheidungsrichter ja das mit
Hilfe eines Computerprogramms gelöst
wird
also es gibt natürlich in Jura diesen
Bereich der Ermessensspielräume der
subjektiven Einschätzung die man für
objektiviert und und und und und und und
es gibt ganz viele juristische Aufgaben
die nie an Maschinen übrigens unter
anderem auch aus
versicherungstechnischen Gründen und
wiederum aus juristischen Gründen nicht
an Maschinen abgegeben werden
was überflüssig wird ist die Arbeit das
ist aber sehr über WhatsApp auch das ist
so die einfachste Fußball gearbeitet
wenn man so in so einer großen Kanzlei
anfängt damit man am Anfang gekriegt ja
mit den langweiligsten Dinge ja also da
muss man aus tausend Texten bestimmte
Sachen raussuchen und so weiter und das
können sie semantische Suchmaschinen
viel besser das kann Chat GPT auch viel
besser das heißt also geistige
Routinearbeit ja die Idee ist was jetzt
das am Anfang machen
ganz leicht anfangen da ist einiges
voneinandersetzbar und das ist eine
verdammt gute Nachricht ja weil die
Juristen sagen ist doch super ja je mehr
langweilige Arbeit in unserem Beruf
wegfällt umso mehr Zeit haben wir uns
auf die kreativ Arbeit zu besinnen und
uns darum zu kümmern
das heißt also die Androhung die hier
unter Chat GPT steht aber die auch in
eben schon hinter Watson stand und bei
sehr vielen digitalen Entwicklung diese
Androhung bedeutet doch wir befreien die
Menschheit von geistiger Routinearbeit
und ich kann in dieser Drohung nichts
Böses sehen ich finde das super also ich
finde das viel wichtiger noch als die
Befreiung von körperlicher routin Arbeit
also körperliche Routinearbeit mache ich
immer noch lieber als geistige
Routinearbeit mein körperliche
Routinearbeit ist sich ziemlich jeden
Morgen an ich wasche mich jeden Morgen
und solche Sachen ne schon alles
irgendwie auch ein bisschen langweilig
ja aber so automatisiert dass man ja
ohne dass es anstrengend ist das
irgendwie ganz gut über die Bühne bringt
na dann denkt man in der Zeit immer was
anderes wenn es langweilig wird so aber
geistige Routinearbeit ist ja meistens
dadurch gekennzeichnet dass die Stadt
total monoton ist das aber trotzdem
nicht anders denken kann dass man sich
auf diese Monot auch noch konzentrieren
muss
ja und wenn das ersetzt werden kann
durch Maschinen dann ist immer so ganz
grundsätzlich und allgemein gesagt eine
positive Entwicklung
ja das ist so das ist so die große Frage
also wenn du ich finde das hat das so
ein paar dunkle Seiten über die man mal
reden muss ich meine was man ja mal
verstehen muss ist was eigentlich Chat
GPT genau ist und ich glaube nach allem
was ich darüber gelesen habe und was ich
so aus Unterhaltungen höre ist das
wissen die von Open ai also die dies
machen selber eigentlich nicht so genau
also und und die sagen auch nicht die
sagen auch nicht genau es gibt
Vermutungen darüber wie viele Seiten zum
Beispiel da
gesammelt wurden ausgewertet worden sind
Eine billionen Seiten habe ich noch
nicht irgendwo gelesen ja das sind alles
also alles alles Daten die
eingespeichert worden sind und
gigantragen das System jetzt in der Lage
ist eigene Texte zu verfassen so aber
aber
open die Firma die das macht die dieses
heiße neu tun jetzt auf in die Welt
gesetzt hat die
ähm sagen das nicht also open air I ist
nicht sozusagen Open Source wie wir die
Fachleute sagen ja man wir wissen das
alles nicht kommen sofort Millionen
Menschen fühlen sich in ihrem
Datenschutz verletzt deswegen hält man
das schon dunkel ja bist du sicher dass
das die als das einzige Motiv ist bin
mir da nicht ganz so sicher ja das
zweite Motive soll man genau erklärt wie
es geht machen die anderen das nach ja
aber das ist zum Beispiel der nächste
Punkt bist du dir sicher dass die genau
wissen was da wirklich passiert deswegen
ist dieser Begriff Maschine
ich habe ganz andere Ängste okay mein
Name ist der Unkontrollierbarkeit im
Sinne von wissen wir eigentlich was der
Algorithmus wirklich macht das wissen
die selber nicht so ganz genau ja siehst
du jetzt die Gefahr weil das sind meine
Punkte da gibt's kleine und große
Gefahren ne also die kleine Gefahr die
könnte darin bestehen dass es dem Gerät
irgendwie unter Kontrolle funktioniert
nicht richtig so große Gefahr die dann
immer so geübt wird ist das System
verselbstständigt sich und wendet sich
gegen
genau und das zweite halte ich für
Science-Fiction Quatsch und das erste
kann aber passieren also wenn man die
die Computer bei Amazon im Lager
ausfallen da gibt es also ganz
komplizierten Code ne wie die Bücher
angeordnet sind und so weiter versteht
kein Mensch versteht nur die Maschine
wenn die Maschinen nicht mehr
funktionieren würde kein Lagerarbeiter
mehr irgendwas finden also dann würde
sozusagen
in die große Dunkelheit aussprechen
genau vor einigen Jahren gab sie
interessant Bestseller über die
Digitalisierung der genau von dieser
Darkside handelte ja dass wir nicht mehr
verstehen was wir tun und dass wir so
abhängig sind und wenn wir irgendwann
wie gesagt der Strom ausfällt oder
irgendein Virus das alles kaputt macht
dann kapieren wir die Welt nicht mehr
halte ich zwar für ein Problem auch für
wirtschaftliches Problem aber wir fallen
ganz andere Kritikpunkte ein als der ich
finde ja mal interessant sozusagen sich
die die die Wirkungsweise vor Augen zu
führen ich habe wie gesagt mit mit
meinem Sohn da länger drüber unterhalten
und der hat mir versucht zu erklären wie
das eigentlich funktioniert der sagt es
musst du dir vorstellen wie ein
gigantisches ja eigentlich wie ein
gigantisches neuronales Netzwerk ja so
die Idee geht schon zurück so in die
90er und so weiter und die ersten
Versuche schon in den 60ern und so und
im Grunde geht's eigentlich um die Frage
du simulierst sozusagen ein ein Neuron
eine Nervenzelle und die kriegt dann
Inputs ja Informationen Reize
und siehst wie sie darauf reagiert und
ob sie darauf reagiert und wann dann der
Punkt gekommen ist an dem sie selbst
einen Output generiert also selbst
anfängt sozusagen wenn du so willst zu
leuchten und Informationen weiterzugeben
und was die weitergibt wird quasi von
einer Funktion Unterschieden ja und er
sagt es der entscheidende Punkt ist
diese dieser riesige Haufen Neuronen
oder der der Nachbau davon ja das sind
ja keine echten aronen die haben
Verbindungen und diese Verbindungen
werden quasi gewichtet ja also wenn du
versuchst diesen Netzwerk was
beizubringen dann veränderst du quasi
die Gewichtungen ja also wenn du jetzt
versuchen würdest z.B dem Netzwerk
beizubringen dass eine dieser Neuronen
blinkt wenn Sie einen Hund sieht ein
Foto von einem Hund zeigst du einen Hund
und sie blinkt nicht und dann schubst du
dieses ganze Netzwerk so lange in die
Richtung dass es näher dran ist zu
blinken und du sagst weitere Hunde und
viele Hunde und tausende und
hunderttausende Hundebilder und
irgendwann mal blinkt das Ding beim Hund
und dann zeigst du auch noch Bilder von
Katzen und schubst es in die Richtung
dass es bei Katzen auf gar keinen Fall
blinkt ja das heißt du schubst es so
lange mit Informationen bist du diese
Gewichtungen veränderst und dann ein
Ergebnis in die Richtung kommst die du
möchtest ja das sind sozusagen diese
diese gigantische Möglichkeit dass diese
neuronalen Netzwerke praktisch jede
Funktion jede Möglichkeit
widerspiegel und abbilden können das ist
jetzt sozusagen technisch schlicht und
ergreifend möglich ja aber das
Interessante ist der Schritt dazwischen
also wenn du diesen Netzwerk beibringen
willst was ein Hund ist ja dann sagt
Lauren dann zeigst du ihm aber in keinem
einzigen Schritt wirklich was ein Hund
ist
und er sagt jetzt passieren dann so
lustige Sachen und es ist ein gutes
Beispiel für mich dafür wie das dann
eben falsch laufen kann ja also du
zeigst ihm zum Beispiel ein Löwen
und jetzt ist ja ein Löwe ist ja
eigentlich typischerweise in der Savanne
unterwegs das heißt du siehst nicht du
den Löwen sondern du hast dann auch
dieser Wanne den Affenbrotbaum dahinter
und und das und das schöne afrikanische
Gras und so weiter ja und das
entscheidet sich dieser dieser dieses
Netzwerk möglicherweise dafür nicht den
Löwen zu lernen sondern den Hintergrund
ja das heißt du musst dann hingehen muss
das Korrigieren ja weil dann jedes mal
wenn du Löwe sagst kommt taucht dieser
Wanne auf ja deswegen musst
du sagen einfach in Wald zu stellen und
dann lernt er immer okay a achtung es
geht doch es geht ja um den Löwen ja
genau so atmosis die wahrnehmen richtig
ne also befreit sie von sind zusammen
genau weil die sind Zusammenhänge sollen
ja
selbstständig hergestellt werden die
sollen ja nicht vorgefunden das ist der
Punkt genau dann kriegst du keinen keine
Sachen mit denen du kannst dann bist du
analytisch zu schwach so und jetzt und
jetzt mal das konkrete Beispiel für uns
Menschen Richard ja jetzt soll die KI
zum Beispiel entscheiden du bist jetzt
in der Bank und die KI soll entscheiden
Bankwesen ist eines das großen Umbrüchen
unterworfen ist muss ich Dir nicht
erzählen KI auch schon reichhaltig im
Ansatz ist wahrscheinlich in dem Bereich
wo KI am stärksten überhaupt so z.B bei
der Frage sollen Leute einen Kredit
erhalten oder nicht ja das darf keine
nicht ja aber würde ich sagen ja wieso
genau weil was kann diese Grenze habe
ich schon schon in dem Buch künstliche
Intelligenz damals gezogen und da bin
ich nicht alleine ja es gibt viele
Menschen die sich mit dem Thema
professionell beschäftigen auch
Informatiker die diese Grenze genauso
sehen und das ist künstliche Intelligenz
darf nicht über menschliche
Lebensschicksale entscheiden so aber ich
sage technisch geht das also die Jacke
hat mit den Daten von vorherigen
Kreditnehmern ja das ist ja sozusagen
statistisch ausrechnen und je mehr Daten
nicht über jemanden habe umso mehr
kriege ich irgendwie ein Bild wie hoch
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass er
seinen Kredit zurückzahlt genau ich kann
auch ausrechnen wie hoch die
Wahrscheinlichkeit von Schülern ist dass
sie ihre Abschlussprüfung schaffen ja
das kann ich alles ausrechnen ich kann
ausrechnen wie hoch die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist bei jemanden bei
wo die Frage steht begnadigen oder nicht
dass der rückfällig wird oder nicht das
Problem ist nur dass solche
statistischen Zahlen mit dem Leben
nichts zu tun haben
aber das ist sehr wichtig weil da denkt
die Maschine anders als der Mensch wenn
du zum Arzt gehst und du kriegst eine
schreckliche Prognose ja du hast eine
ganz furchtbare Krankheit und der Arzt
sagt dir daraufhin also mit dieser
Krankheit lebt man im Durchschnitt noch
drei Jahre
ja dann ist das natürlich sozusagen eine
fürchterliche fürchterliche Situation
für die wichtige Zahl ist die
statistische Zahl drei Jahre für dich
ist die aber nicht wichtig richtig weil
du kannst mit dieser Krankheit rein
theoretisch noch 20 Jahre leben weil
viele Leute auch nach Wochen sterben es
kann auch sein dass du in paar Wochen
tot bist das ist sozusagen dass die
Lämmer der statistischen Zahlen dass sie
eigentlich nur sehr sehr indirekt
überhaupt was aussagen und am Ende finde
ich vielleicht gar keine Relevanz haben
wenn ich jetzt ausrechne dass du zu 47,3
% die nächste Prüfung nicht schaffst was
hast du dann oder weißt du mehr im
Zweifelsfall könnte entstehen dass du
die Flinte ins Korn wirst wenn du sagst
auch so unwahrscheinlich ist das dann
strenge ich mich gar nicht erst an
außerdem wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass im strafgefangen hat dass der
wieder ins Leben zurückfindet und keine
weitere gräuelt hat oder sowas bringt
vielleicht nur bei 10 Prozent ist er
könnte aber zu den zehn Prozent gehören
die schaffen wird jetzt aufgrund einer
statistischen Zahl die nichts mit ihm
und seiner persönlichen Psychologie zu
tun hat nicht begnadigt richtig und das
alles sind viele Beispiele dafür warum
künstliche Intelligenz über menschliche
Leben nicht entscheiden darf das meine
ich und die Frage ist aber also wird das
kommen meine thesis es wird kommen ich
bin mir sicher es wird passieren man
wird dann sagen ja das müsste regulieren
okay dann dein Wort Gottes
Richter zu Ende ne also die die Sache
mit dem Kredit damit man das mal
versteht ja also da werden jetzt diese
diese Intelligenz die Maschine wird
gefüttert mit den Daten vorheriger
Kreditnehmer so jetzt stellt die KI fest
Leute die in einer bestimmten Gegend
wohnen die dieses und jenes Auto fahren
die so und so viele Kinder haben sind
eher nicht kreditwürdig ja was ja
grundsätzlich schon mal bei Menschen die
einem Kredit brauchen keine Überraschung
ist ja dass der Kredit auch ausfallen
kann weil natürlich haben die eher
Probleme Geld zurückzuzahlen sonst
bräuchten sie ja gar keinen Kredit mehr
so fängt das schon mal an jetzt kann es
aber sein dass die Maschine eben nicht
lernt das ist um eine bestimmte Gegend
um ein bestimmtes Auto um ein bestimmtes
Einkommen geht sondern sie könnte
feststellen dass er ärmere Gegenden er
er ärmere Menschen aus einer bestimmten
Gegend häufig schwarz sind und dann ist
diese KI plötzlich schwer rassistisch es
könnte sogar sein jetzt hast du lauter
Gründe warum das nicht kommt nee ich ich
ich will nur sagen aber weil das wollen
wir alle nicht das wollen wir alle nicht
ich sage dir es wird trotzdem passieren
nein nein nein nein nein nein also
technische Fortschritt setzt sich nicht
einfach immer und überall so einfach nur
so durch weil er technischer
Fortschritte ist er setzt sich dann
durch wenn er zu einem Geschäftsmodell
führt und das Geschäftsmodell ist
abhängig von der gesellschaftlichen AK
Distanz der Technik und das ist sehr
wichtig es gibt andere Bereiche also
eine große Revolution die Chat GPT
machen wird ist sie wird wahnsinnig
viele geistige Routinearbeit ersetzen ja
zum Beispiel eben Journalismus ja wie
die Axt im Walde hüten übrigens völlig
zu Recht ja wer so schlecht ist dass er
durch Jetski PPT abgelöst werden könnte
aber tatsächlich ist es ja so das ist
nicht nur eine Frage weil irgendein
Mensch schlecht ist sondern weil die
Arbeitsbedingungen Journalismus sich
eben auch verändert haben und ganz
vieles leider leider geistige
Routinearbeit unter Zeitdruck geworden
hast du gesehen wie der der Aktienkurs
von von was wird wie der abgegangen ist
als die angekündigt haben dass sie genau
das jetzt einsetzen werden also dass die
Maschine in Zukunft Artikel schreibt ich
glaube um 200% oder so unvorstellbar ja
aber ich meine es gibt auch genug
Artikel heute schon die wirken als
hätten Maschinen sie geschrieben
abgesehen davon also ich ich
z.B morgen ist immer über Neuigkeiten
über den Krieg zum Beispiel und dann
finde ich ja die gleiche Meldung in zehn
verschiedenen Quellen das ist ja sowieso
alles jetzt nicht mehr geistige Arbeit
sondern da werden bestimmte
Agenturmeldungen einfach übernommen
übernommen übernommen und da eingestellt
oder nicht eingestellt und so weiter und
auch die Kommentierung wirkt häufig so
als sie von jet-ppt also da finde ich
jetzt auch nicht irgendwie so viele neue
clevere oder überraschende Gedanken drin
und überall da wo es eigentlich
tatsächlich relativ unkreativ ist wird
diese Technik ihren einzuhalten und
warum sollte sie nicht
in anderen Bereichen wird sie ihren
Einzug nicht halten wo sich
prognostiziert wird was ich am
albernsten finde ist die Vorstellung
dass das irgendein Nachteil für die
Kunst hätte
das ist völlig daneben also ich war ja
in meinem Leben weil ich nur drei Bücher
über Digitalisierung geschrieben habe
sehr sehr viel auf digitalkonferenzen
unter uns so und dann gab es ein paar
Jahren entdecke da kam jeder auf
dieselbe Idee und jeder dachte es wäre
ganz originelle Idee von ihm selbst dann
fängt das an man setzt sich dahin und im
Hintergrund spielt Musik tolle
Klaviermusik so dann wird er als erstes
ist ja der Mantel gelüftet das hat gar
kein Mensch gespielt ne das hat eine KI
gespielt und auch eine KI komponiert und
ich erinnere mich an ein Treffen vor
sechs sieben Jahren schon wo jemand
vorführte dass ihr in meine KI hat die
in der Lage ist eins zu eins Rembrandt
sehr zu stellen das rembrans oder einem
brennt jedenfalls also wäre danke
ja also ich würde sagen ja gut das kann
vertracki auch und wahrscheinlich besser
aber richtig als rembran selbst ganz
selten Unterschied
KI kann nie besser sein als rembrand bei
tracikant aber nein das Interessante ist
also ja und und dann zu Wort ich meine
wer geht denn in ein Konzert ja irgendwo
eine künstliche Intelligenz Musik
abspielt da braucht man gar nicht mehr
ins Konzert gehen lassen kann man sich
schenken das kann man sich dann zu Hause
anhören aber es ist doch so und wer
allergrößte Teil des Musik von Musik ja
die Menge mit Emotionalität zu tun hat
hat auch was mit eigenen Vorstellungen
von denjenigen zu tun die diese Musik
schreiben oder aufführen klar ja dass
Sie dass man sozusagen dass diese
Empfindungen die wir da wahrzunehmen
glauben dass sie sich übertragen dass
uns die Persönlichkeit interessiert die
die diese Musik gemacht hat und und und
das heißt also die die künstlerische
Produktion wird doch nicht entfernt
gefährdet dadurch dass man etwas perfekt
nachreifen kann ja das ist das ist genau
der Punkt ich habe dieser Tage einen
schönen Satz gelesen wenn du Künstler
bist und du glaubst dass deine Kunst
durch sowas durch einen Bot gefährdet
ist dann ist deine Kunst Scheiße
hat meistens eine ziemlich ähnliche
Grammatik ja oder die meisten Drehbücher
von von Verfilmungen die man hat weiße
Hollywood sei es im deutschen Fernsehen
ja da weißt du nach zehn Minuten wo der
Hase lang läuft und dann weißt du wann
die Plot points kommen und so weiter das
alles wenn das durch Jetski gefährdet
ist ja zu Recht das finde ich super ja
ich hoffe dass das dazu führt dass man
nichts mehr von der Stange produziert
damit es nicht nach Tschechien die
aussieht sie gibt mir großartige
Geschichte das mitgekriegt Nick Cave
kennst du ne
großer Songwriter der unglaublich schöne
Text der gute Gedanken wahnsinnig klug
Mensch
einem einem jungen Mann
zurückgeschrieben an einem gewissen mag
der ihm mal wieder der berichtet der
kriegt seit der Einführung im November
letzten Jahres kriegt er die ganze Zeit
von Leuten die in einer Art Ehrfurcht
algorithmischer Ehrfurcht vor sich hin
Brummen sondern der das Songs geschickt
die im Stile von Nick Cave erstellt sind
und der schreibt ihm dann lieber Mark
sei mir bitte nicht böse dieses Lied ist
wirklich Scheiße ja und er sagt dass
eben genau das was einen großartigen
Song großartig macht ist eben nicht
seine Ähnlichkeit mit dem was es schon
gibt sondern es ist natürlich etwas
anderes und der formuliert eine tolle
benutzt eine tolle Formulierung und sagt
ein neues Kunstwerk zu schaffen einen
neuen Song zu machen das ist was auf ein
Akt des Selbstmords der alles zerstört
was man in der Vergangenheit produziert
hat ja und er sagt es sind diese
gefährlichen diese herzzerreißenden
Abfahrten die den Künstler über die
Grenzen dessen hinaus katapultieren was
er oder sie als sein eigenes bekanntes
selbst erkennt das ist großartig und
beschreibt an diesen kreativen Kampf den
man da sozusagen kämpft und sagt
irgendwie dass macht mir etwas was das
angeht absolut keine Angst ja in Sachen
Kunst in anderen Dingen wiederum schon
Richard ich sag dir noch mal ein anderes
Beispiel ich würde da noch weiter drauf
gehen weil das sag ich zu Ende
diskutiert damit also du hast ja mich
gefragt wo ich die Gefahren sehe ja oder
die Darkside quasi die ich habe
vielleicht etwas anders hier als du das
ist in der unendlichen Vermehrung des
Trivialen ja also die ganze
Digitalisierung hat das als Nebeneffekt
ja also hoch kreative Leute Informatiker
schaffen Dinge die tendenziell eher
nicht dazu geeignet sind Kreativität zu
entfachen
macht ja nichts anderes als Bekanntes zu
addieren das ist ja der Sinn der Übung
also bereits
vorhandenen Daten etwas zusammenzusetzen
genau ja und ich hatte vorhin ja dieses
Zitat von Piaget angebracht Intelligenz
ist das was man einsetzen wenn man nicht
weiß was man tun soll und ich habe ein
zweites Zitat erfunden als von mir
Kreativität ist was man einsetzt wenn
man nicht weiß was dabei rauskommen soll
und das ist sozusagen kreativitäts
tötend wenn ich nur auf der Basis von
bekannten Bekanntes neu zusammenrühre
ich schreibe gerade in den vierten Band
meiner Philosophie Geschichte zu Ende
und ich beginne ja alle meine Bände mit
einer Bildbeschreibung in diesem Fall
mit einem Werk der klassischen Moderne
was also jeder der sich für Kunst
interessiert kennt das sind die die
Modells von Avignon von Picasso so und
das Buch das Bild ist als es damals
gemalt wurde Anfang des Jahrhunderts von
allen abgelehnt worden selbst von
Picassos besten Freunden weil es
eigentlich überhaupt nichts Bekanntes
mehr hatte anknüpfen konnte heute ist
das Bild für uns die Gründungsakte des
Kubismus der Beginn der Avantgarde Kunst
und vieles andere mehr und die Leute die
es am Anfang verurteilt haben haben ein
Jahr später versucht selber so zu malen
aber in diesem Moment war es einfach
verstörend anders und befremdlich ja ich
meine da nackte Frauen die ich kaum noch
erkennen kann die einen sehen aus wie
Comics die anderen sehen aus wie
afrikanische Masken das ganze Bild sieht
aus als wäre es mit der Machete
zugehauen und so weiter ja hat irgendwie
nichts mehr zu tun mit dem was selbst
die wildesten Maler ja wie mattis oder
so vorher gemalt haben
so und das ist deswegen so beeindruckend
und wahrscheinlich ist es eines der
wertvollsten Bilder der Welt und müsste
man mal die Versicherungssumme erfragen
und deswegen weil es völlig innovativer
und solche völlig innovativ kreativen
Leistungen sind natürlich auf Basis
solcher Computersysteme nicht möglich
wenn aber diese Computersysteme immer
mehr menschliche Bereiche
kannibalisieren
dann wird quasi die ewige Wiederkehr des
bekannten und das ewige neu
zusammensetzen des alten immer mehr Raum
im Leben und in der Gesellschaft
einnehmen und da könnte man befürchten
auf Kosten des kreativen das ist so ein
bisschen was ich denke weißt du ich ich
denke unsere Kinder kommen in immer
vorgefertigtere Welten jetzt werden ihn
auch noch die ganzen alltagsgebrauchst
Texte auch noch alle quasi vorgegeben
und und und und und und und ja wo sollen
die dann noch ihren Raum finden und wo
soll der Nährboden für Kreativität da
sein ja also das ist jetzt kein Urteil
ne das ist nur eine ausgedrückte
befürchte Vorlage zum Nachdenken du
teilst diese Befürchtung mit Heinz Peter
Meidinger das ist der Präsident des
Deutschen Lehrer Verbandes der neulich
bei uns in der Sendung war ging es um um
die Bildungsmisere der dann hinterher
was sagte darüber müsst ihr reden das
wird eine riesiges Thema und das wird
Schule für immer verändern dass du
plötzlich den den Computer fragst die
Maschine fragen Wissens was auf was ist
die Lösung dieser Aufgabe es gibt dann
keine Matheaufgabe mehr die du nicht
lösen kannst du kannst Texte imitieren
du kannst plötzlich Prüfungen ablegen
lassen von der Maschine das heißt das
wird die Art und Weise wie wir lernen
und wie wir Schule begreifen so
befürchtet er für immer verändern was
gibt es denn dazu befürchten also das
wäre ja normal gerne die Gegenrede
halten und würde sagen also ich
unterschätzt die Gefahren nicht aber da
die Schule sich sowieso dringend
verändern muss vielleicht schafft Chat
GPT das ja was ich und meine ganzen
Mitstreiter die alle für eine
Bildungsrevolution gekämpft haben den
letzten 15 Jahren nicht geschafft haben
ja dass man nämlich tatsächlich darüber
nachdenkt dass wie Schule heute
funktioniert sie nicht weitergehen kann
und darf wenn also Prüfungen so sind das
gleiche
gleiche Leistung mit Hilfe eines
computerbots besser geleistet werden
kann als mit Hilfe eines menschlichen
Verstandes
dann liegt das vielleicht daran dass die
Prüfung nicht gut sind vielleicht sollte
man dann andere Dinge prüfen andere
Dinge die eben gerade nicht von
Maschinen geleistet werden die dann auch
für die Berufswelt der Zukunft viel
entscheidender sein soll also vielleicht
bringt uns was endlich die ganz große
Wände hin zur Kreativität da würde ich
jetzt entschieden widersprechen Richard
ich finde ja also ich würde würde ich
wirklich ganz entscheiden widersprechen
ich glaube ja schon dass es irgendwie
wichtig ist dass wir so ein paar Basics
einfach irgendwie drauf haben wirklich
ich treffe ständig Menschen wirklich das
fällt mir wirklich auf also das einfach
so dass Niveau von Allgemeinbildung ist
zum Teil wirklich dürftig geworden das
muss man einfach
besser nie besser als heute in der
Breite das ist natürlich ein Abrede
stellen sprich mal mit Lehrern
nicht solche Sätze nein das gibt's doch
jeder Generation dass sie immer glaubt
dass sie noch über große allgemein nein
nein nein nein
das habe ich nicht gesagt ich bin nicht
der der
ist sehr schlecht gelaunt der Onkel der
ist reinkommt Leute viel besser als
früher einfach durch die Tatsache dass
Menschen sich auf Knopfdruck überall
informieren können das ist die Menschen
heute über die Länder auf dieser Welt
wissen wie viele Leute also wenn man
macht man eine Karte und lass mal den
normalen deutschen Pakistan einzeichnen
ja und sagen das ist Pakistan und dann
dreimal die Welt zurück und stell dir
das mal vor 100 oder vor 50 Jahren vor
insgesamt ist die Allgemeinbildung viel
größer ich ich gebe nur wieder was mehr
Lehrerinnen was mir Lehrer berichten die
mir auch schon in meiner Schulzeit na
die sagen die Schulbücher die wir vor
zehn Jahren eingesetzt haben die können
wir heute gar nicht mehr benutzen
verstehen die gar nicht mehr verstehen
die nicht sagen die ich gebe das nur so
wieder und ich finde schon hat mein
Physikbuch auch nicht verstanden
okay ich hatte teilweise das Buch ja
dass ich zweimal die Woche mitnehmen
musste weil das Physikbuch ja und das
war so ein großes schwarzes Buch und ich
kann mich daran erinnern dass ich da nur
wenige normale überhaupt reingeguckt
habe weil das so eins dieser Bücher ist
also die ist für mich so ähnlich
tatsächlich Chinesisch Fibel dabei
gehabt
es hätte sich erst dann in Sinn
überführt wenn ein Lehrer mir dabei
geholfen hätte das aber nicht so was was
man sich so aufs Knie legt und drin
rumblättert und dann alles versteht und
da habe ich damals übrigens gedacht ne
also es musste eine wichtige
Voraussetzung geben für Leute die Physik
Bücher schreiben sie dürfen nicht Physik
studiert haben sie müssen schlecht in
der Schule in Physik gewesen sein
diejenigen die keine natürliche
Affinität zu diesem Thema haben ja an
dem Punkt müssen sie anfangen
ja ich ich ich glaube trotzdem dass das
die Art wie wir Schule begreifen wie
Schule heute ist wenn du an der an der
Uni Prüfungen ablegen kannst die du gar
nicht in Wahrheit selbst abgelegt hast
sondern den oder Aufgaben Hausaufgaben
gemacht hast Projekte gemacht hast den
Wahrheit an Bord für Dich geschrieben
hat dann wird es tatsächlich schwierig
und vor allen Dingen an Bord in die du
nicht richtig hinein gucken kannst das
ist ja der große Unterschied dass du
nicht mehr wirklich verstehst was da
drin passiert du erinnerst dich Richard
dann das Beispiel vorhin mit mit dem
Kredit ja du könntest ja sagen du
könntest ja sagen warte mal woher
sollten die Maschine wissen dass in der
Gegend von der ich vorhin gesprochen
habe vorzugsweise schwarze Menschen
beispielsweise wurden das könnte man ja
der Maschine einfach verschweigen und da
kommen jetzt kluge Leute und sagen ja
das konnte man in der Vergangenheit so
machen aber das können wir jetzt mit
dieser Technologie nicht mehr machen das
musst Du der Maschine nämlich nicht mehr
sagen das ist genau das Geheimnis von
Maschinen learning dass dass der
Maschine nicht mehr sagen muss sondern
eine Maschine guckt sich an okay was ist
das für eine für eine Gegend also rein
geographisch mit welcher
Wahrscheinlichkeit Leben da welche Leute
die die kennt die so zu demografischen
Daten die weiß selber dass da
vorzugsweise schwarze Menschen
beispielsweise wohnen oder Träger von
pinken Socken um es jetzt mal sozusagen
von der Debatte wegzuziehen und dann ist
die Frage kriegen pinke sockenträger
dann keinen Kredit mehr oder kriegen sie
schon das ist nämlich die Frage oder
noch ein anderes Thema sie übernimmt zum
Beispiel den Rassismus des
Bankangestellten
so viele so viele Bots gegeben genau ja
die sich aus dem Daten an der Leute
gespeist haben
üblen Rassismus so verwandelt haben
genau rassistische Maschine entstanden
also viele Rassisten ihre Kommentare
abgegeben richtig der hat ja aber jetzt
auf die wichtig
finde was hast du der Punkt ist und da
sehe ich die Gefahr ne wenn ein
rassistischer Mensch vor dir sitzt dann
spüren wir das wir merken das wenn ein
rassistischer Gott mit dir spricht
merkst du das nicht
das kriegst nein das kriegst du wir
haben was an diese immer drauf an
Unterricht würde dich sozusagen dann
Schulen ja ja impliziten Rassismus zu
erkennen und ich möchte zur Schule
zurück ja weil wenn ich da vielleicht
übertrieben habe und habe gesagt ach
jetzt kriegen wir endlich die
Bildungsrevolution die beim haben
wollten ja keine Wissensabfrage rein
nicht mehr dann hast Du natürlich einen
Punkt und da denke ich natürlich auch
viel darüber nach ohne Wissen kann man
auch nicht kreativ in seinem Kopf
arbeiten natürlich also irgendwie muss
mindestens Vermittlung ja weitergehen
die Frage ist wie wird die dann
überprüft und das andere wird eben sein
wenn es so ist dass die Nachteile
überwiegend wie offensichtlich der
Präsident der Meidinger vom Lehrer
verwandt meint würde ich natürlich
wahnsinnig gerne wissen ja was wäre denn
sein Gegenvorschlag wie würde er denn
die Schule verändern wollen wollen
von Handys und Computern in der Schule
damit niemand mit dem Stopp Stopp
irgendwelche Texte Verfahren jetzt nicht
zulassen dass du den Armen Herrn
Meidling nein der Präsident der
Präsident der bestimmt sowieso sehr gute
Ideen
er hat nur die Frage gestellt das ist ja
nicht so eine das ist nicht so ein Herz
konservative Knalltüte sondern ein sehr
interessanter Mann
ich will es nur sagen ich habe aber er
hat nur wie du ich hatte nur wie du
einfach schlicht die Frage gestellt wie
gehen wir damit um ja machen ich habe
ihm die Frage beantwortet es geht in
zwei Richtungen die eine Möglichkeit
wäre sich gegen die Möglichkeit so etwas
zu nutzen in der Schule abzuschotten und
die Fenster abzukleben und die zweite
Möglichkeit besteht darin ein
grundlegendes Verständnis von Schule zu
entwickeln ja dazwischen gibt es
vermutlich gar keine Lösung
das meine ich ja und deswegen haben die
Leute die befürchten dass das die Art
und Weise wie wir Schule begreifen wie
wir lernen werden in Zukunft
wahrscheinlich recht das wird das für
immer fundamental verändern gibt dir
noch ein Beispiel Richard wir haben von
über Juristerei gesprochen wenn du wenn
du wenn du ich meine was diese diese
Maschine macht ist ja sie erkennt Muster
ja und und genau genommen ist es
eigentlich so es sind es sind
Milliarden von von Sätzen von von
chat-protokollen von Texten von
Gesprächen die einfach sozusagen also
Buchstaben letzten Endes die
aneinandergereiht werden und eine
Funktion treibt die dann sozusagen in
eine bestimmte Richtung und zwar so
lange bis das Ergebnis ungefähr etwa dem
entspricht was da idealerweise
rauskommen müsste die Gruppe die also
eine ein riesige Haufen Buchstaben
produziert einen weiteren Haufen
Buchstaben mit zum Teil abenteuerlichen
Auswüchsen auch und so weiter ja also
gibt diese schöne Beispiel Sascha Logo
schöne Grüße den ich sehr schätze hat
das in seiner Kolumne dieser Woche
beschrieben sagte die Frage ob Donald
Trump wieder gewählt werden sollte hat
die Maschine gesagt Donald Trump ist
nicht berechtigt jetzt noch mal
anzutreten weil er schon zweimal
Präsident war ja und auf die Frage
welches Säugetier die größten Eier legt
sagt dann Chat der Elefant gefolgt von
der Behauptung elefanteneier sind bis zu
23 cm groß und rund zweieinhalb Kilo
also
aus deiner Sicht immer schlechter
werdender Allgemeinbildung wird weiter
befeuern
genau weißt es ist jetzt einfach sich
über sowas
gibt es so viele Leute ich glaube schon
solche Kombinationen irgendwo von sich
gegeben haben viele Buchstaben ja viele
viele Buchstaben und es werden mit Hilfe
des Algorithmus neue Brüste hier ja ja
irgendwelche Formulierung
sagt wenn man fragt wie heißt das letzte
Buch von Richard David Precht
das will ich dir sagen na mach mal
das letzte Buch von Richard David Precht
das zum Zeitpunkt meines Wissensstands
veröffentlicht wurde heißt wer bin ich
und wenn ja wie viele und wurde im Jahre
2017 veröffentlicht das ist ein Buch
über die Philosophie der Identität
untersucht Fragen und so also der
persönlichen Identität zur
Selbsterkenntnis und zu Bedeutung von
Freiheit und Verantwortung kein einzige
wahre Aussage
was was passt dir daran nicht okay
2007 wäre näher an der Wahrheit ja krass
das war auch jetzt nicht mein letztes
Buch sondern fünftes von 20 Büchern du
wirst du in einer Eitelkeit jetzt
getroffen ja ja so ist das ansonsten
könnte man auch hinwegsehen Buch über
Identität ist es auch nicht wirklich ja
ist übrigens interessant die hat den
gleichen Fehler gemacht wie die
Marketingabteilung meines Verlages
damals und die Marketingabteilung meines
Verlages wollte das Buch nicht unter dem
Titel
und zwar mit der Erklärung dass sie
nicht wüssten ja das also klar wäre dass
der Buchhändler nicht weiß wo er das
Buch hinstellen soll ja cool weil man
denken würde wer bin ich und wenn ja wie
viele ist ein Buch über multiple
Persönlichkeiten oder so geht zum
Schizophrenie und Persönlichkeitsstörung
und sogenannten würde das bei irgendwie
unter Psychologie im Regal stehen oder
unterhalten
und das wäre natürlich blöd oder ein Kim
Gläser und Buch nicht zusammen und so
weiter und so und das interessant das
also aufgrund allein des Titels ne ähm
der der Bot so ähnlich reagiert hat wie
die Marketingabteilung und das irgendwie
falsch Regal sein sortiert hat
cool Markus Lanz und Richard David
Precht haben einen Podcast mit dem Namen
Lanz und Precht Frage ein Chat GPT ist
das ein guter Podcast Antwort das ist
eine subjektive Frage und hängt von
persönlichen Vorlieben und Meinungen des
Hörers ab einige Leute könnten in
Podcast als informativ und unterhaltsam
empfinden während andere ihn vielleicht
langweilig oder uninteressant finden es
ist wichtig zu beachten dass die
Meinungen variieren können und es keine
allgemeingültige Antwort auf die Frage
gibt ob ein bestimmter Podcast gutes
oder nicht aber das ist doch schon mal
eine ganz ganz Weise Antwort also da
muss müssen Leute die Chat gpty
programmiert haben gute Kenner der
Analytischen Philosophie gewesen sein es
ist nämlich eine wichtige Erkenntnis der
Analytischen Philosophie geht zurück auf
die Prinzip ja Ethiker von nur aus dem
Jahr 1903 das Gut keine natürliche
Eigenschaft von Dingen ist das heißt
also ein das kann nicht gut oder
schlecht sein weil er die Eigenschaft
nicht hat sondern gut ist eine
Attributierung eine persönliche
Bewertung und das hat absolut Chat GPT
erkannt so siehst du mal und jetzt und
jetzt sollten wir noch mal irgendwie
darüber nachdenken wie schlau dieses
Ding tatsächlich ist ich habe ich habe
mit mit
diesen mit diesem bot ja es gibt etwas
faszinierendes daran das faszinierende
ist ja dass die Maschine oft Bullshit
erzählt
aber die die Definition von Bullshit ist
ja nicht dass es einfach nur Quatsch ist
die klassische Definition von Bullshit
ja das eigentlich versteht ist ja dass
du etwas mit unglaublicher
Überzeugungskraft vorträgt und es ist
trotzdem Mist ja großer dicker scheiße
auf nicht irgendwie ein kleiner ja groß
so und und er wird aber mit einer
solchen Überzeugungskraft vorgetan ist
das Gefühl hast ist ein ganz großartiger
Scheißhaufen über den du da sprichst ja
und das hat damit zu tun dass die Leute
die die so ein Ding programmieren die
sich damit beschäftigen ja immer dann
die Frage beantworten müssen die die das
Ding trainieren war das hilfreich und
die Maschine und das zeigt halt auch wo
die Reise dahin geht die Maschine hat
gelernt dass die Antwort dann häufiger
positiv ausfällt wenn dir Ton stimmt
wenn diese Überzeugung mit drin ist ja
also wenn sie möglichst überzeugend laut
so leicht autoritär daher kommt was sie
dir zu sagen hat dann ist es besonders
häufig als hilfreich empfohlen worden
Leben ganz genau das Motivation also die
Frage ob du etwas für wahr oder falsch
hältst was du nicht überprüfen kannst
und jetzt mal als recht als Kind wo du
sowieso nichts überprüfen konntest
jedenfalls früher nicht weil du noch
kein Internet hattest ja genau das
glauben muss ist dahin doch von der
gefühlten Autorität und der gefühlten
Kompetenz des Sprechers ab ob du eine
Sache ernst genommen hast oder nicht hat
das meine ich doch und das zeigt mir
Wahrheiten ist ja psychologischen
Faktoren abhängig genau keine reinen
logisch rationale Angelegenheit so und
das zeigt dir aber wo die Reise dahin
geht weißt du deswegen eher wenig das
das zeigt sozusagen wie viel da
plötzlich stimmt im Sinne von wie wie
leicht es ist sozusagen dann wirklich
den Menschen zumindest zu imitieren an
bestimmten Punkten lass uns doch mal bei
einer anderen Thema sprechen Kuss
Richard weil das vorhin kurz angeklungen
ist du hast vorhin gesagt dass sozusagen
der alles was ihm digitalen stattfindet
ist quasi unendlich reproduzierbar ja
also der der gigantische Erfolg von von
großen Unternehmen ist ja diese
digitalen Unternehmen ist ja die
Skalierbarkeit genau gigantisches
Skalierbarkeit also wenn du wenn du
Facebook bist dann kannst du sozusagen
an einem Tag eine Milliarde neue
Accounts erstellen du kannst um eine
Milliarde neue Accounts quasi wachsen
wenn du der Hersteller von was was ich
Eisenbahn Waggons bist kannst du das
nicht sondern musste erstmal Eisen
einkaufen und Stahl einkaufen und dann
brauchst Du neue Hochöfen und keine
Ahnung was alles das dauert Jahre bist
du so ein Unternehmen also aus China
genau gerissen Lieferketten ja genau so
und das dauert Jahre bist du das
skaliert hast länger interessanterweise
ja während das eine immer kürzer geht
und der in der klassischen Industrie
dauert es immer länger genau so heute
ich habe heute morgen versucht an
Medikament zu kriegen und dann sagte die
Frau das gibt's gerade nicht habe ich
nicht dann sag ich zu ihr ja dann können
Sie es heute Nachmittag bestellen und
dann sagte sie zu mir sie haben mich
nicht verstanden ich kann das einfach
gar nicht mehr bestellen weil das gibt
es gerade nicht sagt aber in welcher
Apotheke gibt es das denn dann sagte sie
haben mich immer noch nicht verstanden
in keiner Apotheke das ist einfach nicht
zu haben Ende der Durchsage so das ist
bei Facebook anders ja die können genau
und das ist auch hier anders und jetzt
jetzt kommt mein Punkt sicher wie
gefährlich ist es für die Demokratie
in einer Zeit in der alles so furchtbar
polarisiert ist weißt du wenn z.B auf
einer Seite wie reddit ja da sind
meinetwegen immer ungefähr eine halbe
Million Leute online als Beispiel wenn
diese halbe Million der Meinung ist
tendenziell es ist eine gute Idee der
Ukraine mit Waffen zu helfen
ja dann können in St Petersburg noch so
viele Trolle herumsitzen und können in
ihren Kommentarspalten dagegen
Anschreiben ja die Schergen von Putin
und können sagen nein und das geht gar
nicht und die böse NATO und die
Amerikaner verdienen nur an diesem
Waffen und so weiter alles was man sich
dann immer so erzählt
und und versuchen sozusagen diese
Meinung zu beeinflussen das Ding ist
auch ein paar tausend Petersburger
Trolle werden nicht gegen eine halbe
Million Schwarm Intelligenz ankommen ja
wenn die die Meinung haben es ist eine
gute Sache die Ukraine zu unterstützen
und eigentlich war das Internet ja immer
genau das eine zutiefst demokratische
Veranstaltung wo sozusagen am Ende eine
Meinung die wirklich eine
Mehrheitsmeinung ist die setzt sich
jetzt durch aber jetzt frage ich mich
entsteht da jetzt plötzlich die
Möglichkeit Stichwort Skalierbarkeit das
Ding wirklich gigantisch zu manipulieren
also wenn da jemand rein schreibt der
klingt wie ein Mensch der argumentiert
wie ein Mensch wo du dann drauf klickst
und du stellst fest ach so der hat ja
auch eine eine Chat history der taucht
auch irgendwo weiß ich nicht auf einer
anderen Seite auf und auf der Seite auch
noch auf und bei telegram tauchte auch
ob der muss doch gar nicht intelligentes
geschrieben haben es geht nun den
Nachweis wenn ein menschlicher Moderator
verstehen will ist das ist das ein Wort
oder ist das ein echter Mensch der da
geschrieben der dort geschrieben das ist
offenbar ein besonders interessierter
Mitbürger teile seine Meinung nicht aber
das schreibt ja so ja was ich jetzt
nicht verstehe Markus also die die
Möglichkeit Meinung zu beeinflussen
durch Bots aber seine sozialen
Netzwerken sowieso nein ich weiß aber
durch diese Art von Wort durch diese Art
der Skalierung die da jetzt plötzlich
möglich ist aber die Skalierung so
Intelligenz zu machen
Facebook einsetze und so weiter die
haben sich selber Wirkung nein das weiß
ich aber und mehr Meinungen dort
auftauchen können auch jetzt rein
theoretisch manipuliert nein natürlich
können Sie das aber nicht dass sie das
immer sind und so weiter aber die machen
der Manipulierbarkeit sind doch schon
jetzt Tür und Tor geöffnet ich sehe da
sozusagen bei Chichi PT keine genuin
neue Qualität weil die Skalierung nicht
größer ist
besteht darin dass es so unglaublich
gutes Richard das ist so gut ist dass du
einen Song im Stil von Nick Cave
plötzlich imitieren kannst dass ich ein
Buch einen Text im Stil von Richard
David Precht schreiben kann dann klingt
es so als wärst du da plötzlich
möglicherweise oder kann nicht
definitiv nicht nein ich bin also sicher
vielleicht doch das reicht doch ja und
um was zu machen also
zur Seite in meinem Stil wo was drin
steht was ich nicht sage oder nicht
gemeint habe und was man strafrechtlich
verfolgen kann und dass jemand das
einstellen dass Menschen lesen und dass
ich dann sozusagen dieses Gerücht nicht
mehr los werde meinst du sowas das ist
das ist das eine und Unternehmer die
Möglichkeit
es ist so unglaublich gut und es kriegt
eine Qualität das ist das worauf ich
hinaus will eine Qualität bei der wir
uns glaube ich immer schwerer tun zu
unterscheiden was da eigentlich passiert
und wenn du wenn du dir zum Beispiel im
Journalismus immer die die Versuche
kommen und das wird passieren ich meine
ein Wort ist jederzeit in der Lage einen
Text zu schreiben indem man Meghan und
Harry doof findet jederzeit Tag und
Nacht das das das ist ganz einfach zu
bewerkstelligen also da kannst du
richtig Meinung machen weil schwierig
gemacht wird ohne dass du bewusst
Meinung machen willst passiert doch wenn
der Bot das Wasser ist ein häufigen
Verknüpfungen vorfindet reproduziert ja
und zum Beispiel Meghan und Harry
unglaublich viele Leute die ganz ganz
ganz doof und Geld und das geil und so
weiter finden
ja ich habe überhaupt gar keine Meinung
wenn Mensch mich nicht interessiert dann
ist das Prinz Harry
0,0 Gefühle für ja
guten Menschen die so das Klima schützen
und damit die Privatjet um die Welt
fliegen ich mag dich bestimmt ja genau
bestimmt ein unglaublich sympathischer
doppelmoralist aber das sind wir alle
und deswegen habe ich nichts deswegen
habe ich nichts gegen nein nein es geht
um was anderes dann wird wenn über
irgendjemand eine Mehrheitsmeinung
besteht dann wird diese Mehrheitsmeinung
künstlich weiter befeuert doch das ich
rede noch gar nicht von böse Absicht ich
rede einfach wenn in einem bestimmten
Kontext mit einer Person bestimmte Worte
immer wieder benutzt werden dann macht
der Bot das auch das heißt das ganze ist
doch dann eine gigantische Maschine ja
so Verstärkung von Vorteil
und dann sind wir wieder bei dem was ich
am Anfang gesagt habe dass diese
digitalen Mittel zur Trivialisierung
beitragen also nicht zur Kreativität die
zum anderen denken nicht zum neu denken
sondern es ein unendliche
bestätigungsmaschine von bestehendem
sind und darin sehe ich in der Tat die
allergrößte Gefahr die dahinter ist noch
lange bevor ich mir Gedanken darüber
mache ob irgendein Geheimdienst eine
feindliche macht ein durchgeknallter
Milliardär oder sowas das zur
Meinungsmanipulation benutzt
der beste Schutzschild gegen
uneingeschränkte Manipulation ist das
Geschäftsmodell wenn ich weiß dass Chat
GPT total manipuliert ist ja dann
verliert es eine ökonomischer Bedeutung
nicht dass das nicht passieren wird das
wird mit Sicherheit passieren aber das
ist sozusagen zum reinen Werkzeug
irgendwelcher Machenschaften ist daran
kann man kein ökonomisches Interesse
haben und ich verlasse mich immer noch
da drauf das genau wie bei Facebook auch
dass das ökonomische Interesse immer am
Ende immer größer ist als das
manipulative Interesse wir werden jetzt
bei bei mask sehen und bei Twitter ob
das so ist oder nicht so ist aber
bislang war das eigentlich so
Maske ist ein gutes Stichwort anderes
Beispiel Richard ein Tesla bot von Musk
ne
Gedanken spielen der kann nicht mit 99
prozentiger Wahrscheinlichkeit sicher
von A nach B bringen
in seinem Auto ein Mensch kann das nur
zu
95%. folgerichtig wenn wir sagen würden
okay dann machen jetzt ab sofort die
Roboter das Geschäft dann fahren uns
Roboter durch die Stadt oder würdest Du
geht ja trotzdem den Menschen nehmen
naja es geht ja nicht also ich gehe ja
fest davon aus dass in den komplizierten
Großstädten Roboter diese
Fahrdienstleistungen Verlangen sich
nicht übernehmen können
aus wegen der Kreuzungen und aus
diversen Gründen ja bei dieser Städte
nicht dafür angelegt sind und weil der
Prozess selbstfahrende Autos zu
entwickeln sehr einfach ist im Vergleich
zur Anpassung dieser selbstfahrenden
Autos ein unberechenbare hochkomplexe
Verkehrssituation in mein Team mein
Thema ist Richard sozusagen an welchem
Punkt wird die Maschine den Menschen
ersetzen also es geht um die Frage
sozusagen wie gut muss die KI sein ja
sind wir zufrieden wenn der Bot
irgendwann in 90% aller Fälle die
richtigen Antworten gibt sind wir
zufrieden mit 95 wollen wir 99
also wenn er solche klatschen News
reproduziert so oder macht oder sowas
reicht noch 25 % reicht immer noch 10%
mehr ist als das was
genau also da wäre bei 10%
Wahrhaftigkeit ja wenn das der Mann wäre
ja für all die Klatschblätter ja
kampfsportale die es gibt und
Gleichungen das wäre ja schon gigantisch
also die können sich ja nur verbessern
dadurch aber wenn es jetzt um das Jura
Examen gibt dann wird man mit zehn
Prozent eben nicht auskommen also es
kommt ja sehr darauf an ja Juristen zum
Beispiel ist ist ja auch ein Thema mit
Leuchten interessanten Text darüber
gelesen welche vor welche
Herausforderung das Juristen stellt man
der Albtraum von Juristen ist ja wenn
sie Dinge nicht mehr begründen können
und wenn die KI zu einem Urteil kommt
und sagt es ist so und so und so meine
rechtliche Einschätzung ist so und so
und so dann beginnt doch erst die
eigentliche Arbeit des Juristen das
Wesen der Juristerei ist doch die Suche
nach der richtigen Begründung die du dem
Richter im Zweifel vorträgst nur die KI
sagt die nicht wie sie es macht weil
selbst die Macher der kariert also wir
wieder bei den Machern von Open die
wissen gar nicht mehr irgendwann
wirklich was der Algorithmus genauso
macht versteht aber Begründung schreiben
sie würden diese Begründungen auf die
gleiche Art und Weise machen wie sie
ihre sonstigen Texte machen okay also
sie würden das ganz ganz vielen anderen
Begründungen die alle eingespeist sind
die würden sie somit miteinander
kombinieren und die quantitativ
wahrscheinlichste Lösung dahinschreiben
so dass also Begründungen am Ende schon
dabei rausgehen und was ist was ist mit
Verantwortung Richard jetzt anderes
Beispiel da machst du natürlich einen
großen Sack auf klar wir wissen mal ganz
kurz noch mal kurz streifen ja also wenn
du wenn du sprichst zum Beispiel über
über die Medizin Radiologie
über
Auswertung von von Röntgenbildern zum
Beispiel andere Dinge muss jetzt jemand
also KI sagt man die kann da Muster
erkennen ist viel besser als der Mensch
die kann das alles eigentlich viel
genauer man kann viel besser Diagnosen
stellen was wenn diese Diagnose falsch
ist wer übernimmt dann die Verantwortung
wenn der Tumor der dort als vermeintlich
gutartig da steht weil die KI sagt nee
nach allem was ich weiß nach den Daten
mit denen ich gefüttert worden bin ist
das Ding hier kein Problem und am Ende
ist der Patient trotzdem tot nach sechs
Monaten wer übernimmt dann beginnt
künstliche Intelligenz nicht über
menschliche Lebensschicksale entscheiden
wie ich am Anfang schon gesagt habe und
diesen Punkt haben wir natürlich in der
Diskussion und selbst von Auto schon
haben wir auch in vielen anderen
Bereichen wir verzeihen einer viel
programmierten Maschine nicht ja oder
einer viel reagierenden Maschine nicht
was wir einem Menschen
notgedrungen verzeihen müssen also auch
ein Arzt kann ja eine falsche
Entscheidung sein
der Arzt die falsche Entscheidung fällt
wenn müssen wir am Ende ob uns das passt
oder nicht sagen dass auch nur ein
Mensch der hat sich angestrengt und
Beweise nachweisen können er hat am
besten Wissen und Gewissen gehandelt und
dann gehen wir mal von aus ja dann
finden wir das furchtbar dass er so
gehandelt hat aber wir können wir werden
ihn nicht zwingend verklagen es gibt
doch Menschen die verklagen dann den
Arzt das ist schon richtig wenn ich aber
weiß das war eine Maschine die hat so
entschieden dass und das und das zu
machen und daran ist mein Angehöriger
gestorben und das verzeihen wenn der
Maschine nicht und ich finde aus guten
Gründen und wenn es sich um solche
Entscheidungen handelt die wird der
Maschine aus guten Gründen nicht
verzeihen und zwar wir verzeihen die
deswegen nicht weil die Maschine ja nur
deswegen eingesetzt ist weil sie perfekt
sein soll weil sie ja eben die
Fehlbarkeit des Menschen nicht haben
soll wenn sie dann aber trotzdem einen
Fehler macht dann verzeihen wir das
nicht genau das ist der Grund warum wir
solche Entscheidungen Maschinen nicht
überantworten dürfen also Richard ich
dank Desserts wann interessanter
Austausch und ich muss dir zum Schluss
noch schnell etwas vorlesen weil jetzt
haben wir ja alle gehört sozusagen
wieder eine Haltung dazu ist eine sehr
skeptische alles klar
noch mal zusammengefasst die Ersetzung
geistiger Routinearbeit wird von mir
grundsätzlich erst einmal sehr begrüßt
und ich trauere nicht alle dem hinterher
was vorher Menschen langweiliger Weise
machen mussten was in Zukunft Maschinen
machen diese Sache sie ist sehr positiv
Realisierung und der Verstärkung von
Vorurteilen genau und was ja nicht
trivial und banal ist ja ich wollte nur
zum Schluss noch ganz kurz Vorlesen die
Kollegen haben die Maschine mal gebeten
eine Unterhaltung zwischen Dir und mir
zu genau diesem Thema auf schreiben und
die Maschine schlägt folgendes vor
willkommen zu einer weiteren Ausgabe von
lands und Brecht wir werden heute über
Chat GPT sprechen ein innovatives
künstliches intelligenzsystem das von
open-ei trainiert wurde und dann sagst
du ja ich denke dass die künstliche
Intelligenz eine große Herausforderung
für unsere Gesellschaft ist und dann
sage ich ja aber Chat GPT ist nicht nur
einfach ein künstliches Wesen es ist ein
sehr fortschrittliches System das in der
Lage ist menschenähnliche Konversation
zu führen und dann sagst du ja das ist
wahr Markus es ist beeindruckend wie
weit die Technologie gekommen ist ja das
sind alles so allgemeine Sätze die jeder
andere auch an dieser Stelle sagen kann
und das kann GPT ganz großartig genau
jetzt den Menschen mindestens eben wird
vielleicht sollte Chat in die Politik
gehen
also wenn ich überlege wie oft wurde in
der Politik ja kopiert werden von
Sprecher zu sprechen dann ist das der
ideale Anwendungsbereich ich wollte
gerade sagen ich danke Dir sehr Richard
bis bald danke tschüss
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF